volunteers help us direct resources more
efficiently here in the city anything
that a police officer can do it pretty
much can do we look like any other
police officer on the street the budget
cut for the city could soon cause a
strain on their resources us officers
will mean more crime police may be
looking at some serious layoffs in the
new year and the cuts could affect
several local communities police
departments across the country are
struggling to keep their city safe while
facing budget cuts Redlands California
might have an answer with one of the
largest volunteer police programs in the
country their violent crime rates
actually dropped after they lost 25% of
their force in 2007 we wouldn't be able
to provide the level of service that I
believe the revans residents have grown
to be accustomed to if we didn't have
our volunteer program
lieutenant Travis Martinez supervises
the program which uses volunteers as
patrol Rangers for city parks traffic
control administrative duties if you
want to volunteer here at the Redlands
Police Department we'll find a place for
you and sometimes for more demanding
positions like reserve field officers
they can't arrest they do have police
powers they are armed they have the same
equipment that the police officer has
the reserve officers come from all kinds
of backgrounds from priesthood to car
dealerships very different working at a
church and the police department I
became the chaplain for the police
department about 15 years ago and that's
how I got involved with Redden's Police
Department and I enjoyed being out with
the other officers enjoyed doing things
so I decided to go through the Academy
I've always want to be a police officer
but when I graduated high school I got
into the car business and that career
just took off whether these volunteers
are giving up their time out of a sense
of service or because they just want to
be police officers and can't get hired
right now they help out the city
immensely they're huge for our
department it's enabled us to keep doing
things that we normally do where we come
in handy is handling all of the of the
non serious crime calls the city just
basically doesn't have the money to pay
a full-time police officer to handle
traffic control handle crowd control but
their supervisors say they are well
prepared to handle these kinds of
incidents because they are thoroughly
trained they have to complete the exact
same
training program that already lasted us
it's not like we'll hire somebody right
away and put them in a car and expect
them to know everything they are getting
a great foundation to do the work they
need to do and they wouldn't be deployed
out there we didn't have their full
confidence once trained they blend in
with the rest of the force the average
citizen wouldn't know that we're
volunteers I mean when you you look at
either of us when we're in uniform we
look like any other police officer on
the street and none of the volunteers
uniforms or equipment comes out of the
city budget our volunteer program is
completely self sustainable they raise
their own money they buy their own cars
they buy their own uniforms they buy
their own equipment none of the money
comes out of the general fund and they
get a lot of those that money through
donations that includes the shining
pride of the department the volunteer
staffed pilot program its accrued one
plane one officer in nearly 30 volunteer
pilots in less than five years they call
it a force multiplier because it can do
many things at once reducing the need
for as many officers on the ground to
act as the force multiplier for the
department and not only saves manpower
but it can also save time and money
redlands efficiency has served as a
model when that other cities are taking
note of there's been a number of cities
that have contacted us regarding our
volunteer program and I believe they're
replicating our efforts and other cities
while their volunteer program serves as
a great example of how to keep a city
safe with a tighter budget Redlands is
not alone there are roughly a quarter of
a million police volunteers throughout
the country contributing millions of
hours and the number only seems to be
growing it's benefited our department
tremendously just raises the level of
service exactly